recht auf kurzarbeitergeld seine ruhe
hat eigentlich die regierung zurück wann
haben sie den mut irgendwie alles
zurückzunehmen zu sagen jetzt ist alles
wieder safe die fragen reißen nicht ab
und das ist auch kein wunder so was wir
jetzt haben wir alle noch nicht erlebt
eine unsichtbare bedrohung des corona
virus breitet sich über den ganzen
globus aus ein virus das nur ein ziel
hat sich zu vermehren
ein virus das alleine nicht überleben
würde in unseren menschlichen körper
eindringt um sein unheil anzurichten und
es springt von mensch zu mensch macht
viele matt und krank und tötet sogar und
wir widersetzen uns dem eindringen mit
drastischen mitteln mit quarantäne
grenzschließungen dem shutdown des
alltags dass in dieser situation die
fragen eher mehr werden und nicht
weniger ist logisch und darum sollen
ihre fragen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auch heute abend wieder im
mittelpunkt dieser sendung stehen wir
wollen so viele fragen wie möglich
beantworten
expertinnen und experten aus der ganzen
republik konnten wir gewinnen die uns
bei dieser aufgabe helfen einer davon
professor harald lesch schöne grüße nach
münchen kommen hallo
er lässt ganz kurz wissenschaft gegen
virus wie weit liegt das virus vorne
ja es hat auf jeden fall einen vorsprung
wir sind gerade dabei diesen vorsprung
zu verkürzen und je schneller und je
besser die gesellschaft auf die
wissenschaftlichen vorschläge die er von
der politik momentan umgesetzt werden
reagiert umso schneller können wir das
virus überholen und dann werden wir
eines tages da stehen mit dem impfstoff
und dann kann man das virus stopp
stoppen
vielen dank dass sie dabei sind und wir
sprechen gleich ganz ausführlich
miteinander und weitere gäste sind bei
uns in berlin zugeschaltet ist der
virologe professor jan felix drexler von
der charité berlin schwimmen abend ja
schön genannt und hier im studio bei mir
begrüße ich die psychologin antje
leopold schön dass sie bei uns sind dr
felix zimmermann rechtsexperte im zdf
auch er ist dabei und der medizin
journalist dr christoph specht ganz
herzlich willkommen und kai klose der
hessische gesundheitsminister schön
genannt
was haben wir vor es soll um den
neuesten stand der virusforschung gehen
um die maßnahmen die unseren alltag
nahezu zum erliegen bringen und
natürlich auch um die frage was wir alle
jetzt tun können beziehungsweise müssen
was passiert mit uns wenn das
öffentliche leben still steht auch darum
soll es gehen und ganz wichtig oder fakt
wem kann man in diesen zeiten eigentlich
glauben
beginnen wir aber mit diesem stacheligen
kleinen monster das zurzeit die ganze
welt in atem hält das virus verbreitet
sich schnell sehr schnell das wissen wir
viele menschen erkranken einige auch
schwer menschen sterben daran
aber was unterscheidet das virus von den
uns bekannten werden
warum kann corona so einen immensen
schaden anrichten und warum sterben in
manchen ländern deutlich mehr als andere
darum soll es im ersten teil unserer
sendung gehen die todesrate von cisco
von 2 ist die zahl die am meisten angst
machen
fachleute nennen sie die falt
sterblichkeit
in deutschland liegt sie im vergleich zu
italien bei 0,3 prozent was eine schwere
grippewelle endet ganz anders in italien
eine todesrate von 7,7 prozent bedeutet
das fast 8 von 100 patienten verstärken
etwa 30 mal so viele wie in deutschland
ist der seine brust und vielleicht
irritiert und gefährlicher geworden
wie wahrscheinlich ist es überhaupt dass
ein virus mutiert ein virus kann sich
extrem schnell fortpflanzen eine
evolution im turbogang
hinzu kommt statt einer dna mit zwei
strängen haben coronaviren nur eine rna
damit fehlt ihnen der zweite strang als
kopierschutz bei jeder zellteilung
können sich fehler einschleichen
aber das grippevirus ist ein rna virus
das sich ständig verändert besonders
drastische veränderungen des grippevirus
haben immer wieder pandemien ausgelöst
bekanntestes beispiel die spanische
grippe von 1918 die weltweit millionen
todesopfer gefordert hatte kleine
veränderungen im erbgut helfende gegen
die reisewege der viren nachzuvollziehen
die erste bayerische infektionswelle mit
cisco v2 konnte eindeutig auf china
zurückgeführt werden
[Musik]
der erste corona fall in baden
württemberg hatte seine quelle dagegen
sicher in italien
[Musik]
die gute nachricht kokona viren besitzen
ungewöhnlich gute reparaturmechanismen
eine gefährliche mutation ist daher
nicht so schnell zu erwarten
die hiv pandemie in den 80er jahren
zeigt in der evolution des virus ist es
ein nachteil tödlicher zu werten
ein schnell versterben der patient kann
keine anderen patienten mehr anstecken
daher ist hiv über die zeit weniger
aggressiv geworden
doch was ist dann der grund für die
vielen toten in italien
die sterberate ist immer nur eine
vorläufige zahl
sie vergleicht die toten mit den
bestätigten infizierten die zahl der
tatsächlich infizierten kann weit größer
sein
doch als infiziert gilt nur wer ein
positives testergebnis hat die
laborkapazitäten reichen in allen
ländern für gerade mal einige tausend
proben am tag bei einer bevölkerung von
mehreren millionen menschen
in italien wurde das virus viel später
entdeckt als bei uns die folge ein
massiver rückstand bei den tests und
eine hohe dunkelziffer an infizierten
einen großen einfluss auf die sterberate
hat auch die altersstruktur der
gefundenen fälle die daten aus china
zeigen ein 70 fach höheres risiko für
die ganz alten gegenüber den ganz jungen
dazu kommt das virus ist umso
gefährlicher je mehr vorerkrankungen der
patient mitbringt alles typische
krankheiten die im alter auftreten
deutschland hat früh flächendeckend
getestet die meisten infizierten fand
man dadurch bei den aktiven menschen im
mittleren alter
ganz anders italien
nach einer ungeliebten ausbreitung hat
man keine chance mehr alle verdächtigen
zu testen
stattdessen prüft man nur noch menschen
die mit schweren symptomen ins
krankenhaus kommen und das sind die
alten bei denen die krankheit regelmäßig
schwer bis tödlich verläuft über das
virus und seine gefahr wollen wir
sprechen mit professor felix drexler von
der charité in berlin
drexler kork arona viren sind für sie
keine unbekannten wann haben sie die
erste bekanntschaft mit krone gemacht
wir haben vor etwa zehn zwölf jahren
angefangen nach sarahs corona werden
unter anderem kone wir in den
fledermäusen in europa zu suchen das war
mitunter unter der leitung von christian
drosten der auch hier an der charité ist
und wir konnten damals auch das erste
europäische ascona wir uns das ist
überhaupt nicht das virus über das wir
gerade reden aber eben ein genetisch
verwandt das virus komplett
charakterisieren und haben das auch vor
zehn zwölf jahren dann publiziert und
das war somit die einstiege in die
chronobiologie eine frage die wir immer
wieder auch gestellt bekommen was
passiert eigentlich wenn wirklich 70
prozent der bevölkerung des virus hatten
so heißt es ja immer wird es danach noch
weitere ansteckungen geben ja klar aber
es wird eben nur noch vereinzelte
ansteckung geben weil einen für ihn war
das virus nicht mehr ausreichend
menschen findet dies noch wann dieses
weitergegeben werden kann weil eben so
viele menschen immun sein werden dass
die herdenimmunität die so genannte
herdenimmunität die flächendeckende
schnelle ausbreitung so wie wir sehr
leider gerade erleben nicht mehr
durchführen können wird herr professor
drexler wir haben in dieser sendung ganz
viele zuschauer fragen an heute und die
letzten tage viele fragen gesammelt
eine will ich ihnen gerne vorspielen ich
möchte wissen wie lange wird diese
dieser theater
dieser pandemie in deutschland und
weltweit dauern ja wird die krankheit
jetzt ganz auszurotten sein oder werden
wir damit leben müssen wir 20 damit
leben müssen
ganz klar also das wird uns nicht so
bald verlassen leider passieren wird ja
zwei konkrete vorhersagen kann man aus
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlicher sicht
nicht machen
wie lange das anhalten wird oder dass es
wäre unseriös
ja aber es ist wir können wir können uns
orientieren an den anderen menschlichen
kroner werden es gibt ja neben sassuolo
virus viele andere corona werden die
auch den menschen infizieren können die
sind schon ganz lange mit uns und
infizieren uns immer wieder und sind ja
auch nicht weggegangen nicht obwohl die
annehmen dürfen dass sich diese viren
und das neue saas bewohner virus 2 gar
nicht so anders verhalten voneinander
zumindest keine belastung
das ist jetzt grob simplifiziert aber
das können wir schon annehmen und ich
glaube nicht dass das neue bild das
dieses neue menschliche virus weg gehen
wird sobald eine frage die wir auf
youtube gesehen haben die uns anders
gestellt wurde kann man sich mehrfach
anstecken
ja ist auch eine komplexe frage also
erst ganz prinzipiell im verlauf eines
menschenlebens ja wahrscheinlich das ist
immer natürlich wir wissen eben noch
nicht so viel aber es ist auch wieder in
analogie zu den uns bekannten
coronaviren wahrscheinlich dass man sich
im laufe eines lebens mehrfach anstecken
kann aber nicht in dieser pandemie also
wenn man man darf annehmen dass wenn man
sich jetzt in dieser ersten großen
durchseuchung der menschheit mit dem
noro-virus 2 infiziert dass man doch
eine gewisse zeit zumindest einen
immunschutz hat okay professor felix
drexler vielen dank fürs erste wir
kommen jetzt von der wissenschaft zur
politik und genau diese beziehung spielt
er den jetzigen tagen eine ganz
besondere rolle
darüber und über die aktuelle situation
wollen wir uns erhalten mit klose dem
hessischen gesundheitsminister noch mal
einen schönen guten abend genannt wie
kann man sich eigentlich die
zusammenarbeit ganz konkret vorstellen
also wer sind ihre hauptansprechpartner
wie läuft die zusammenarbeit aus ihrer
sicht die zusammenarbeit läuft aus
meiner sicht sehr gut wir haben in
hessen 24 o logische schwerpunkte in
marburg wo ja auch seinerzeit der
marburg virus entdeckt und bevor stuhl
ein großes sich hochsicherheitslabor und
in frankfurt an der uniklinik eine
weitere sehr gute virologie mit beiden
arbeiten wir sehr eng zusammen kanzlerin
merkel hat vorher festgelegt dass
deutschland ab sofort die grenzen
schließt das einreiseverbot für alle
nicht eu bürger wird sofort umgesetzt
ist das zum beispiel ein ergebnis einer
engen zusammenarbeit zwischen politik
und wissenschaft
ja wir sind ja in einer situation in der
wir uns stündlich im grunde mit neuen
entscheidungs entscheidungsbedarf
konfrontiert sehen und neue
entscheidungen treffen müssen und da
spielt die wissenschaft und die art und
weise wie wissenschaft auf diese
pandemie schaut eine ganz entscheidende
rolle für uns ist da das
robert-koch-institut natürlich als das
zentrale institut maßgeblich für die
entscheidungen die wir treffen die wir
gemeinsam treffen als länder mit dem
hund es gab es in den letzten tagen auch
viel diskussionen wegen den föderalen
strukturen dass manche maßnahmen einfach
ein bisschen dauern dass es
unterschiedliche zuständigkeiten gibt
wie sieht es mit dieser zusammenarbeit
aus hat er jedes bundesland seine
eigenen experten
na wir haben unsere eigenen experten
rubys eben für hessen auch gesagt hat
natürlich tauschen wir uns sehr eng aus
damit wir uns auch immer alle auf dem
gleichen stand halten das hat am anfang
ein bisschen geruckelt das sind auch
situationen die kann man nicht üben
sondern da müssen wir jetzt in der
situation in der lage mit umgehen
aber wir kommunizieren extrem eng mit
dem bundesgesundheitsminister mit dem
robert koch institut und dem
gesundheitsministerium und ministern der
länder
wir haben eine weitere zuschauer frage
die ich auch ihnen ganz gerne vor
spielen würde wenn ich keine habe wo
gehe ich hin und lasse mich testen
also für hessen würde gelten sie rufen
ihren hausarzt an oder rufen die 11 6 11
7 die nummer des ärztlichen
bereitschaftsdienstes an bitte anrufen
nicht einfach hingehen beschreiben was
ihr für symptome haben und entscheidend
ist dann sie haben symptome und entweder
hatten sie kontakt zu einer bestätigt
infizierten person oder sie waren in
einem der risikogebiete unterwegs wenn
das zusammenkommt dann sind die
voraussetzungen dafür da dass ihr
hausarzt oder der ärztliche
bereitschaftsdienst sagen wird begeben
sie sich bitte an eine der testzentren
heinz testzentren das wir aufgebaut
haben und dort werden sie getestet und
bekommen dann auch ein ergebnis aber das
ist die voraussetzung dafür man kann
nicht einfach da hingehen und sagen ich
möchte mal getestet werden dafür sind
unsere labor und test kapazitäten
einfach insgesamt nicht ausgerichtet
herr minister es kommen wir zu ganz
praktischen fragen auch zu den maßnahmen
in deutschland jetzt sollen viele
geschäfte schließen eigentlich nur noch
lebensmittel und apotheken offen sein
friseure zum beispiel frage die wir
immer wieder gestellt bekommen haben die
machen weiter auf was gibt es dafür ein
grund für also das ist ja ein ergebnis
der einigung zwischen bund und dem
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten und wir haben uns
entschieden wir übernehmen diese liste
jetzt so wie sie ist das mit dem friseur
ist in der tat eine diskussion weil man
sich zwangsläufig sehr nahe kommt es ist
jetzt erst mal in der liste es kann sein
wie ich sagte wir sind alle stunden auch
am überlegen müssen wir an diesen dingen
noch was ändern
jetzt sind die friseure erstmal bei den
geschäften dabei die zur grundversorgung
gezählt weil das heißt offen bleiben es
kann aber gut sein dass ich auch daran
noch etwas ändert ganz sicher ist alles
was zur absoluten grundversorgung gehört
lebensmittel apotheken die bleiben in
jedem fall geöffnet und dazu passt auch
genau unsere nächste zuschauerfrage
schauen sie mal werden die supermärkte
auch einfach mal geschlossen oder
bleiben sie voraus dass sich auf
ich bin sehr sicher dass alles was zur
lebensmittel grundversorgung gehört
geöffnet bleibt
ob das in weiteren verlauf dieser
pandemie
dazu kommt dass man bestimmte
einschränkungen macht was die zahl der
gleichzeitig anwesenden betrifft also
das lässt sich jetzt nicht ausschließen
aber ich bin ganz sicher dass es keine
schließung geben wird klose
bundesumweltminister aus hessen ich
danke ihnen sehr für die informationen
dankeschön
im laufe der sendung werden wir uns noch
fragen wie wir eigentlich mit dieser
unsicherheit der angst und auch dem
plötzlichen stillstand in vielen
bereichen des lebens umgehen sollen auch
viele rechtliche fragen haben wir von
ihnen bekommen die wir beantworten
wollen
genau wie die frage was wir aus den
solchen der vergangenheit eigentlich
gelernt haben alles wichtige und
spannende themen jetzt lernen wir aber
erstmal ein neues wort nicht
pharmazeutische intervention was so viel
heißt wie schulen schließen
ausgangssperren soziale kontakte
eindämmen
viele der einschränkungen haben wir
schon und keiner weiß wie es genau
weitergeht jeden tag jede stunde kommen
neue meldungen zu maßnahmen die länder
oder die bundesregierung festlegen
frustrierend daran ob die zahl der
neuinfizierten dadurch eingedämmt werden
kann
das sehen wir erst in ein bis zwei
wochen der blick ins ausland lohnt sich
zum beispiel nach taiwan stillstand in
deutschlands schulen auch kitas bleiben
zu die auswirkungen auf familien und
wirtschaft sind groß selbst kleine
veranstaltungen sind abgesagt bars clubs
und cafés alles geschlossen
die bahn schränkt ihren betrieb ein die
bundesregierung spricht eine weltweite
reisewarnung aus es herrscht
ausnahmezustand
die ländergrenzen zu einigen
nachbarstaaten sind geschlossen
pendlerverkehr ausgenommen italien
spanien frankreich verhängen landesweite
ausgangssperre
auch tschechien und österreich schränken
die bewegungsfreiheit der menschen ein
ohne triftigen grund darf niemand mehr
seine wohnung verlassen
europa kämpft gegen die verbreitung des
corona virus europa hat sich zum
epizentrum dieser pandemie entwickelt
abgesehen von china werden aus europa
mehr infizierte und tote gemeldet als
aus der gesamten restlichen welt das
sind mehr fälle pro tag als sie china
zum höhepunkt der krise gemeldet hat das
robert koch institut erklärt in europa
tiroler madrid ganz italien die region
contest in frankreich zu risikogebieten
das öffentliche leben steht still
es ist die totale abschottung
doch kommt sie rechtzeitig und ist sie
jetzt noch sinnvoll
die zahlen sprechen eine deutliche
sprache vergleicht man beispielsweise
die schweiz mit taiwan
die landfläche ist ähnlich auch wenn
taiwan drei mal so viele einwohner hat
so meldet die schweiz über 2.300
infizierte taiwan dagegen nur 77
ähnliches gilt für singapur vietnam und
thailand und das trotz der geografischen
nähe zu china
der grund asien erlebte in den letzten
zwei jahrzehnten drei große epidemie
2003 kursierte sachs die sterberate
betrug 9,5 prozent 2009 und 2010
grassierte die schweinegrippe h1n1 den
zahlen der whu zufolge lag die
sterblichkeit bei 0,02 prozent 2015 hieß
der erreger märz die sterberate bei
diesem virus lag bei 34,5 prozent
die sterberate für das neuartige
coronaviren ist aktuell unklar
dagegen wird immer deutlicher viele
asiatische länder haben aus den
vergangenen epidemien gelernt sie
schulten mitarbeiter mit übungen wie
diese modernisierten krisenreaktion
pläne verschickten waren hinweise und
verhaltensregeln per sms und sie haben
die gefahr früher erkannt als westlicher
länder
so hat taiwan schon anfang februar die
einreise aus china verboten maßnahmen
die erfolgreich waren
das zeigt die entwicklung der absoluten
zahlen der infizierten während sie in
deutschland exponentiell ansteigen
bleiben sie in vietnam oder taiwan auf
vergleichsweise niedrigem niveau
vietnam produzierte eigenes diese
kampagne zum richtigen händewaschen
solche maßnahmen denen die ausbreitung
des virus ein
zusammen mit der sogenannten sozialen
distanzieren
welchen unterschied die soziale
distanzierung machen kann
das zeigt diese simulation wird der
soziale abstand konsequent gewahrt
erkranken kaum menschen die längst zu
sehen werden keine maßnahmen getroffen
hier rechts im bild ist das virus kaum
aufzuhalten
das heißt hygienemaßnahmen einhalten
händeschütteln vermeiden
die erfahrungen aus china singapur
taiwan und anderen ländern zeigt ganz
deutlich konsequentes testen der
bevölkerung die kontrolle und
einschränkungen von sozialen kontakten
kombiniert mit einer mobilisierung der
gemeinschaft kann infektionen verhindern
und leben retten
um gefährdete personen zu schützen haben
viele asiatische länder schnell reagiert
und verschiedene maßnahmen kombiniert
die konsequente durchsetzung ist
kulturell bedingt in asien leichter doch
deutschland europa und andere westliche
staaten sollten von den erfahrungen
lernen und sie in unsere kultur
übersetzen
viele fragen drehen sich natürlich um
den ganz praktischen alltag jeden tag
müssen wir alle entscheidungen treffen
die in so einer zeit wie jetzt plötzlich
nicht mehr so leicht zu treffen sind
was darf ich was soll ich was hilft das
virus zu bekämpfen und so mich und
andere menschen zu schützen
genau für diese fragen haben wir den
medizin journalisten und arzt dr
christoph specht eingeladen unter
sprechen nochmals herzlich willkommen
ich fange gleich an mit einer
zuschauerfrage der uns über youtube
erreicht hat kann man über kleine wunden
an der hand zum beispiel sich infizieren
ja im prinzip ja das virus braucht nur
eine eintrittspforte das geht auch dort
also da muss man auch entsprechend
hygiene waren und eben sauber verbinden
gleich die zweite zuschauerfrage
hinterher
die temperatur ist es gerade schönes
wetter der frühling kommt alle wollen
eigentlich diese schönen tage genießen
könnte dieses warme wetter uns in die
karten spielen also das virus das leben
schwerer machen
man hat ja am anfang die hoffnung dass
sich das neue corona virus wie die
krippe etwa halten würde das heißt im
winter es sie da im sommer geht sie weg
im nächsten winter kommt die nächste
session aale grippe das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so es bleibt
uns wahrscheinlich erhalten und trotzdem
wird der sommer uns helfen nicht nur
wegen der höheren temperaturen was das
corona wir uns nicht ganz so mag sondern
auch weil wir dann eher draußen sind und
größere abstände haben im winter sind
wir drin in engen räumen das ist die
ideale variante für die
tröpfcheninfektion also weitere
zuschauer frage kommt jetzt als kleiner
film meine frage ist dass sich im januar
erkrankt bin quasi an fieber und
halsschmerzen in meine frage ist ob es
sein kann dass ich vielleicht damals
schon den corona dieses hatte die folgen
waren allerdings relativ mild bei mir
ist warschau ist eher unwahrscheinlich
im januar aber die italiener hatten das
auch nicht gedacht und da gab es die
fälle wahrscheinlich auch schon längst
im januar ausgeschlossen ist es nicht
jetzt testen würde gar keinen sinn
machen denn der test weist das virus
selbst nach und das ist ja gottseidank
längst weg man muss dann warten bis man
die sogenannten serologischen test hat
wo die antikörper nachgewiesen werden
und die bleiben ja über längere zeit da
und dann wird man eines tages sagen
können ja er hatte mal corona
es geht jetzt ganz viel um die frage wie
kann ich mich aber auch die
allgemeinheit schützen wenn ich jetzt zu
hause bin zum beispiel muss sich auf
besondere hygienische sachen achten muss
ich mehr putzen darf ich mit meinen
kindern jetzt nicht mehr kuscheln bis zu
der frage darf ich meine frau eigentlich
noch küssen gibt es ratschläge die uns
ein bisschen durch diese zeit helfen
also wir lernen jeden tag dazu das ganze
ist eine situation die eben nicht nur 12
tage anhält sondern sicher länger die
menschen die in enger gemeinschaft leben
wie zb ein paar die werden jetzt durch
weitere distanzierungen gar nichts
retten so zu sagen sondern die sind ja
eh schon so eng beieinander
ich glaube dass es nicht praxisnah hier
eine trennung vornehmen zu wollen was
die reinigung der wohnung an geht vor
allem auch oberflächen da ist es sicher
sinnvoll ein bisschen mehr zu machen als
sonst auch jetzt nicht wahnsinnig
übertrieben händewaschen bleibt das
entscheidende an oberflächen weiß man
kann das virus eine zeitlang in
anführungsstrichen überleben
man weiß aber nicht genau ob noch
genügend viruspartikel dann darauf sind
dass ich wirklich jemand an steckt das
sind wahrscheinlich eben dann doch nicht
die vielen tage die wir jetzt immer
hören sondern vielleicht doch nur
stunden das ist jedenfalls die hoffnung
hinter christoph specht fürs erste
vielen vielen dank für die informationen
der feind ist das virus
alles wird getan um diesen feind zu
besiegen
wieder stand der forschung bei dem
impfstoff aussieht dazu kommen wir
gleich wie auch zu den rechtlichen
fragen die sich jetzt in dieser
ausnahmesituation ergeben zb wenn man in
quarantäne muss ich stelle mir das jetzt
mal vor ich sitze in quarantäne oder
irgendwann kommt dann doch die
entscheidung man darf nur noch in
dringenden ausnahmefällen die wohnung
verlassen
meine frau und ich haben drei kinder wir
leben auf 100 quadratmetern super viel
platz ist das nicht zu fünft reicht aber
im normalfall im normalfall wenn wir
jetzt mehrere wochen alle nahezu
eingesperrt sind keiner raus gehen darf
wie soll das gut gehen
bei solchen fragen kann sie helfen tipps
und kann sie auch gegen julia leopold
guten abend schön dass sie da sind
angelina jolie und kate entschuldigung
von leben wollte
sie sind psychologin müssen sich
plötzlich auch mit solchen fragen
beschäftigen
es ist eine extremsituation für viele
menschen die jetzt in einer wohnung
sitzen eben wenig rausgehen sollen viel
zeit miteinander verbringen sollen
was macht diese ausnahmesituation
mitmenschen naja die menschen sind im
moment sehr aufgeregt es ist ein
bisschen so als hätten sie tagelang
energydrinks getrunken
man muss mit der situation umgehen dass
man plötzlich konzerte nicht besuchen
kann in dem man gern gegangen wäre oder
den eigenen geburtstag nicht feiern kann
das sind wir nicht gewöhnt und das ist
natürlich ein größerer belastung für die
haben sie die ratschläge tipps was
sollte man machen weil wie kann man mit
der situation umgehen naja wir beklagen
uns doch immer dass es nicht zeit haben
jetzt haben wir mal zeit jetzt können
der zeit miteinander verbringen müssen
uns vielleicht manchmal auf die dinge
besinnen die wir schon immer mal gerne
machen wollten mal wieder ein hobby
ausgraben miteinander spielen
wir versuchen irgendwie die zeit gut rum
zu bringen was kann man gegen diese
konflikte machen die ja schon
wahrscheinlich auch auftreten werden
also die stimmung ist vielleicht gereizt
alle sind wie gesagt haben so ein
bisschen wie aufgedreht
immer geht es um ein thema was was
könnte da der ratschlag sein wie kann
man auch vorher schon so ein bisschen
diese konflikte vermeiden
ja das kommt natürlich sehr darauf an
die familien sonst mit konflikten
umgehen ja ich glaube zu einem guten
teil ist das natürlich auch normal da
gibt es dann eben konflikte mit
jugendlichen mit kindern die angespannt
sind
doch irgendwie durch und so stück für
stück auch die normalität vielleicht
annehmen und uns vor allem so ein
bisschen beruhigen
also von wegen immer gibt es noch ein
thema vielleicht muss das auch mal ein
anderes thema geben also auch wirklich
mal ganz bewusst beiseite lassen und
tatsächlich viel miteinander land in den
vier räumen vielleicht auch in den
eigenen vier wänden
also die leute genießen das irgendwie
auch das ist mal was anderes ist wenn
viele kinder haben ja auch natürlich
fragen
die merken ja genau was da gerade
passiert und dass da was nicht stimmen
zu hause sind in der schule wie würden
sie kinder mit über corona sprechen
also ich finde vor allem was diesmal
wichtig authentisch zu sein die kinder
dürfen ruhig mit kriegen das auch uns
das beunruhigt das kriegen sie sowieso
mit und dann ist es sinnvoll mit kindern
kindgerecht darüber zu sprechen und
wichtig ist ihnen zu vermitteln dass wir
uns jetzt darum kümmern also die
erwachsenen werden das schon regeln
und das können wir ihnen erklären warum
sie jetzt zu hause sind das ist dafür da
um das zu regeln also dass sie diese
sicherheit auch wieder erlangen freund
vielen vielen dank viel reden habe ich
gelernt und ein bisschen die ruhe
bewahren ist glaube ich gar nicht
entscheidend vielen dank für ihren
besuch hier bei uns welche veränderungen
jetzt zu sehen sind und ob diese
katastrophe am ende sogar positives
bewirken kann
diese fragen gehen jetzt an professor
harald lesch
ja was ist jetzt neben den medizinischen
herausforderungen unsere größte
gesellschaftliche herausforderung was
wir eben schon gehört haben wie im
privaten so auch gesellschaftlich vor
allen dingen ruhe bewahren also fast
hätte ich den alten britischen satz
genommen keep kam also auf jeden fall
ruhig ruhe bewahren und sich daran
orientieren was die offiziellen seiten
sagen also was sagen was sagt die
besatzung also was sagt unsere regierung
was sagen unsere institutionen
er muss sich ein bisschen so verhalten
wie in einem richtigen notfall also ruhe
bewahren sich an dem orientieren was der
fall ist sich informieren vor allen
dingen sich aufklären was ist los und
dann eben tatsächlich das tun was
angesagt ist das ist glaube ich das
allerwichtigste und für die gesellschaft
bedeutet insbesondere solidarität eben
nicht nur üben sondern ausüben
tatsächlich sich umschauen wo kann ich
helfen gerade die jüngeren sind jetzt
auch aufgefordert sich für die ältere
bevölkerung einzusetzen man sieht es ja
auch schon es gibt ja viele angebote von
allen seiten
dass jemand versucht zu helfen indem man
zum beispiel für ältere einkauf usw also
also was jetzt auf einmal das thema
solidarität kein fremdwort mehr sondern
es wird ganz wichtig für alle hier und
mit welchen veränderungen in der
gesellschaft rechnen sie langfristig
glauben sie da wird was auch hängen
bleiben werden wir daraus lernen
also es ist ja so wir haben es ja eben
auch schon gehört die entschleunigung
war ja noch nie so schnell also so
schnell ist diese gesellschaft ja noch
nie auf null runter gebremst worden
wir waren es ja gewöhnt dass unsere
terminkalender laufen dass wir
eigentlich dass diese gesellschaft
reibungslos funktioniert auch ein
bisschen auf kante genäht ist
ich glaube dass diese tage des corona
die wie das werden wir nicht vergessen
wir werden hoffentlich daraus eine ganze
menge an lehren ziehen was ist für uns
besonders wichtig welche arten von ja
von handlungen sind für uns müssen für
uns in zukunft zur daseinsvorsorge
gehören
wir haben es ja auch eben in den bericht
gesehen wie zum beispiel in
verschiedenen asiatischen länder damit
umgegangen worden ist welche virus
epidemie über diese länder gegangen sind
und welche konsequenzen daraus gezogen
worden sind
ich denke wir werden insgesamt alle
deutlich mehr lernen wir sind ein teil
der natur solche epidemien werden
möglicherweise durch den klimawandel
angetrieben häufiger über uns kommen das
heißt wir werden eine ganze menge lernen
müssen und werden eine ganze menge tun
müssen und werden eine ganze menge neu
organisieren dass in deutschland wird
diese erfahrung der isolation darüber
haben wir gerade geräten ein neues
bewusstsein schaffen
aufbruch der individualisierung na ja
wir sind es bis jetzt gewohnt gewesen
dass unsere autonomie unsere freiheit
immer mehr und mehr wächst ich weiß
nicht ob sich noch daran erinnern vor
einigen wochen gab es noch debatten dass
man keine verbots partei sein will und
man müsste doch mehr auf freiwillig
setzen und so weiter und das heißt wir
sehen aber jetzt auf einmal wenn es
wirklich kritisch wird dann muss man
verbieten da muss man einschränken
das heißt wir werden eine ganze menge an
neuen erfahrungen machen die sich
natürlich auch im gesellschaftlichen im
politischen bereich niederschlagen
werden ich kann nur hoffen dass wir
genügend lernen daraus unter anderem
eben auch lernen im politischen diskurs
darauf zu achten wer es kompetent und
wer es ihnen kompetent wie können die
institutionen zusammenarbeiten und wie
wichtig ist es dass eben nicht nur ein
starker staat da ist sondern auch
institutionen die sachkompetenzen ich
glaube das ist das alles
beste was wir aus dieser krise bis heute
lernen können wir sehen dass unsere
institution gut funktionieren und wie
ich immer sage diese ganzen
dampfplauderer wissenschafts verächter
aber auch die fake news produzenten das
sind nicht die leute denen wir unser
land an vertrauen sollten
professor harald lesch vielen dank
bis hierhin zu den angesprochenen kommen
wir in der sendung gleich über ich muss
das wort noch mal sagen nicht
pharmazeutische interventionen haben wir
ausgiebig gesprochen also über
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die das ausbreiten
des virus behindern aber klar ein
wichtiger baustein im kampf gegen korona
ist ein möglicher impfstoff das
wettrennen um den rettenden stoff ist im
vollen gange das haben sie gerade in den
letzten tagen mitbekommen wer jetzt bald
einen impfstoff präsentieren kann ist
der held der retter das geht so weit
dass die der us-amerikanische präsident
eine tübinger firma in die usa holen
wollte und viel geld geboten hat um sie
anzulocken um die mögliche lösung für
sich für sich zu beanspruchen
das hat nicht geklappt die
wissenschaftler bleiben in deutschland
und wollen auch den impfstoff wenn er
dann entwickelt ist allen zur verfügung
stellen
gute nachricht aber wann wird das sein
wie lange dauert es noch ganze netzwerke
große teams arbeiten gemeinsam an einem
ziel ein impfstoff gegen korona seit
mehr als 150 jahren gibt es
schutzimpfungen kaum eine andere
medizinische innovation hat weltweit
mehr menschenleben gerettet
doch es fehlt ein impfstoff gegen das
neue corona virus us crew vom 2 deshalb
kann sich das virus zu verbreiten ist
salz v2 einmal im körper bringt es in
unseren zellen ein
es bringt sein gegen real in den
zellkern und programmiert diesen um so
dass die zelle zu einer art viren fabrik
wird das virus vermehrt sich massenhaft
und die zellen sterben ab
und so sieht das in der realität aus
baaske v2 viren verlassen eine gekaperte
zelle kürzlich festgehalten mit einem
elektronenmikroskop das neue virus
treibt wissenschaftler in der ganzen
welt zur eile an
es geht um menschenleben auch in der
schweiz am inselspital in bern ist man
am wettlauf für einen impfstoff
beteiligt der immunologie martin
bachmann arbeitet mit chinesischen
kollegen an einen möglichen kandidaten
wir haben jetzt gezeigt man kann häuser
immunisieren und sie geben sehr gute
antikörper antworten und was wichtig ist
die antikörper antworten können das
virus zerstören neutralisieren und das
ist eigentlich der grundsatz aller
impfungen bachmanns ziel eine sogenannte
aktive impfung
dabei werden teile des virus verabreicht
sie sind für uns ungefährlich aber das
menschliche immunsystem ist alarmiert es
reagiert wie bei einer tatsächlichen
infektion und bildet die passenden
antikörper tritt der ernstfall also eine
echte infektion mit dem virus ein kann
der körper das virus mit den antikörpern
neutralisieren
lasko v2 kann nicht mehr in die zellen
eindringen und sich vermehren
dieser schutz ist dauerhaft eine weitere
möglichkeit die passive impfung hier
werden künstlich hergestellte antikörper
geimpft diese heften sich an die
virusoberfläche und neutralisieren das
virus eine passive impfung wirkt sehr
viel schneller aber im gegensatz zur
aktiven variante hält der schutz nicht
an das problem normalerweise dauert die
zulassung eines impfstoffs mindestens
sechs jahre aufgeteilt in drei phasen es
muss umfassend getestet werden
selbst wenn man die einzelnen phasen
verdichtet dauert es immer noch
mindestens ein jahr die gefahr
mögliche nebenwirkungen würden nicht
erkannt
diese deutsche firma ist bei der
impfstoffentwicklung ganz vorne mit
dabei
mit einem neuen ansatz die tübinger
arbeiten nicht mit sco v2 direkt sondern
nur mit seinem bauplan
so kann sich hier auch niemand
infizieren die eine gute und sichere
alternative ist weil wir nicht den
gesamten jahres dazu brauchen sondern
wirklich nur ein bestimmtes kleines
element ja und das reicht ja dann die
zellen so zu trainieren dass sobald es
da ist dieses ein element erkannt wird
und die antikörper die dicken diesen
virus schützen und so sieht das
verfahren aus anhand des virus bauplans
stellt das unternehmen ein boten molekül
eine sogenannte mrsa her
diese m rna transportiert die
information innerhalb der körperzellen
zu den sogenannten ribosomen
so können unsere zellen selbst die
proteine herstellen die unser
immunsystem zur antikörperproduktion
braucht
nach eigenen angaben könnte cure weg im
frühsommer mit den klinischen studien
beginnen
die forschung läuft auf hochtouren
professor drexler in berlin von der
charité an sie noch mal die frage wie
weit ist die impf entwicklung diese
frage kriegen wir ja dauernd gestellt
sie wahrscheinlich auch was können sie
uns darüber sagen ja also das ist
natürlich ein riesenthema
und ich will dass du auch gleich vorweg
sagen dass meine spezialgebiete virus
revolution und diagnostik sind und
sicherlich nicht im stoff entwicklung
des sehr viele sehr viele sehr sehr gute
kollegen die sich exklusiv damit
befassen und ich glaube man muss
feststellen es gibt einfach im moment
sehr viele verschiedene ansätze
impfstoffe zu entwickeln und das ist
natürlich erstmal sehr sehr
begrüßenswert weil wir moment also für
werk in kirberg er wir wissen ja noch
gar nicht welcher impfstoff am ende
wirklich der beste sein wird
und das ist natürlich nicht das einzige
das beste bedeutet natürlich nicht dass
er das macht das tut was er machen soll
dass er also die menschen die
immunisiert worden sind schützt vor
einer schweren erkrankung vielleicht
sogar dafür die chancen verringert dass
das virus dann weitergegeben werden kann
wenn dieser mensch infiziert obwohl er
vielleicht nicht krank ist aber ganz vor
allem muss man erst mal festhalten das
ist unfassbar schwierig ist und komplex
und dass wir alle diese ansätze parallel
brauchen werden um später sehen zu
werden was können wir herstellen
in entsprechenden masse auch dass wir
auch wirklich alle versorgen können das
kann auch gut sein dass es am ende gar
nicht die eine gewinner vakzine gibt
könnte ich mir zumindest vorstellen das
wissen wir jetzt noch nicht
ich habe vorher gesagt wer zuerst
liefert ist der held wie groß ist denn
eigentlich der wettbewerb wie kann man
sich das vorstellen
ja also auf jeden fall extrem und
berechtigterweise ja auch ein sehr
großer wettbewerb ich finde was zu
machen was sie etwas sehen was er zu
betonen ist es dass es natürlich neben
dem wettbewerb auch viel synergie gibt
wo viele erfahrungen ausgetauscht werden
und das ist eigentlich der kollege lösch
hat es ja vorhin schon betont das war
ihre einstiegsfrage
er hat jetzt wer nicht vorne wir oder
das virus und eine sache die man beim
thema impfung einfach auch noch mal
sagen kann ist dass wir ein bisschen
glück im unglück haben weil sie haben
sich an spieler gesagt saß gab es 2000
und 2003 gab es also schon mal ein
solches saß corona virus nur eben nicht
dass ihr ziel sondern ein genetisch
verwandt des virus vor allem in china
ist das aufgetreten und wir haben
unfassbar viel gelernt aus dieser zeit
wir haben also seit dieser zeit haben im
prinzip 15 jahre zeit forschung
forschungszeit gehabt und diese
ergebnisse sind sicherlich nicht alle
übertragbar auf das neue virus aber eben
bei weitem nicht umsonst also wir haben
einen riesen vorteil und er hilft uns
natürlich jetzt dass wir so weit von
sind und das ist das positive in all
diesen schwierigen in diesen schwierigen
zeiten dass man sich daran auch
festhalten kann wie schnell ist eben
doch jetzt klar wir haben noch nichts
aber es geht doch eigentlich unfassbar
schnell für neues virus
wir kennen das wie lang zwei monate drei
monate das finde ich eigentlich muss man
auch mal festhalten
letzte frage wie schwer ist es für sie
alle und für die wissenschaft dass ich
dieses virus ständig verändert also da
an impfstoff zu entwickeln ist doch
wahrscheinlich eine die richtige
herausforderung würde ich nicht sagen
also corona während verändern das hatten
sie auch im einspieler gravierend
verändern sich ja tatsächlich ein
bisschen weniger als zum beispiel
anderer rna viren weil sie eben diese
reparatur enzyme mitbringen
die viele andere rna viren überhaupt
nicht haben
das heißt hier haben wir im gegensatz
zur influenza zu grippe nicht das
problem dass wir jedes jahr einen neuen
impfstoff eigentlich brauchen weil das
virus immer ausreichend man sagt driftet
also sich ausreichend verändert um von
den um so dass der mensch durch die im
monat wird nicht mehr geschützt ist vom
letzten jahr oder nicht mehr komplett
geschützt ist ich glaube das problem
haben wir hier nicht so da diese krone
werden genetisch und gleich auch einen
genetisch das heißt von ihrer
proteinstruktur relativ stabil sind
wir haben aber ein anderes riesenproblem
nämlich dass die infektion vor allem in
der lunge jahr abläuft
vor allem in der lunge sicherlich später
können auch andere organe befallen sein
aber dass es erstmal einer kranken die
sich in den atemwegen abspielt
und eine impfung die man zb in den
muskel gespritzt so wie eben die
grippeimpfung oder die meisten gängigen
grippeimpfungen muss erst mal
ausreichend immunantworten das sind vor
allem hier auch antikörper aber
natürlich auch t zellen also zelluläre
immunantwort die antworten die müssen
alle ja erstmal so ausreichend vorhanden
sein dass er in der lunge auch schützen
und das ist nicht trivial
vielen dank professor drexler nach
berlin für ihre einschätzungen das war
hoch spannend war auch die hohe
wissenschaft aber ich glaube wir haben
viel gelernt vielen dank gerne viele
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer diese zeit
stellt sie uns alle vor große
herausforderungen für keinen ist das
einfach und jeder will natürlich wissen
wie ihnen die konsequenzen betreffen
nicht nur gesundheitlich auch ganz
konkret was für rechte und pflichten
habe ich in dieser zeit und auch dazu
gab es fragen von ihnen felix zimmermann
aus der zf rechts redaktion ist jetzt
hier bei mir im studio mal herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank dass du hier
bist ganz konkrete frage die wir auch
immer höheren auf verschiedenen
plattformen und netzwerke
urlauber sollen jetzt aus dem ausland
nach deutschland geholt werden
ist das nur ein angebot oder muss man
zurück liegen also körperlicher zwang
wird er nicht ausgeübt das ist genau wie
bei der reisewarnung das ist eben eine
empfehlung aber eine dringende
empfehlung wer sich da jetzt sag mal
wieder setzt trotzdem abreißt oder im
ausland bleibt dem tod hat wirklich eine
zuspitzung der lage dass er nicht mehr
zurück kann und wenn dann eine situation
eintritt das vielleicht am reiseziel der
kroner virus sich stark ausbreitet die
medizinische versorgung dann dort
schlechter ist als bei uns dann droht
wirklich gefahr für leib oder leben
deswegen die bitte oder warnung des
ministers die sollte man auf jeden fall
befolgen
hier noch eine frage von unseren
zuschauern die persönlich gestellt wurde
ich habe einen flug nach tunesien
gebucht und ich wollte wissen ob ich ihn
halt mein geld zurückerstattet bekommen
ja das ist so jeder kann bei einer reise
immer zurücktreten wenn sie noch nicht
angetreten ist aber normalerweise bleibt
man den großteil der kosten sitzen
und jetzt ja diese reisewarnung und das
ist eine besonderheit dagegen
außergewöhnliche umstände und in diesem
fall kann man von der reise zurücktreten
und kriegt den vollen reisepreis
erstattet funktionen bekommen gleich
nochmal zu dir vielen dank fürs erste
das was wir jetzt erleben ist ohne
beispiel in unserer jüngeren geschichte
niemand von uns hat so einem
ausnahmezustand die erlebt quarantäne
grenzschließungen ein shutdown des
alltags und in diesem kampf ist die
wahrheit auf das erste opfer denn
inzwischen kursieren überall meldungen
von vermeintlichen experten die als
angebliche theorie verkleidet ihre
meinung geben so schnell verbreiten wie
das corona virus nicht nur eine epidemie
ancona viren auch eine info demi eine
flut an viralen nachrichten das ergebnis
statt vertrauen in medizin forschung
politik und verwaltung allgemeine
verunsicherung wie können wir sinn von
unsinn unterscheiden
immer mehr nachrichten über das kroner
virus prasseln auf die menschen ein
immer mehr sind beunruhigt wissen nicht
mehr was richtig oder falsch ist aber
auch bedacht wir sind gerade am anfang
dieser völlig neuen situation den
ausnahmezustand für alle
man weiß halt einfach nix und das ist
wiederum was ein unsicher macht das noch
das schlimmste uns bevorsteht
[Musik]
auch dieses junge paar bleibt
vorsorglich zu hause während sie noch
arbeitet kuriert er sich aus hoffentlich
nur eine erkältung
doch sie sind verunsichert wie soll man
sich jetzt richtig verhalten
vor allem in den sozialen medien
kursieren einige nachrichten die schwer
einzuordnen sind
eine sprachnachricht die über whatsapp
verbreitet wurde ist besonders
beunruhigend
laut der uniklinik wien sollen corona
patienten mit besonders schweren
symptomen zuvor ibuprofen eingenommen
haben ihren tieren sowieso an den
hinweisen des robert-koch-instituts was
am ende stimmt wissen wir nicht ich
glaube dass man trotzdem solche
medikamente im handel nehmen sollte wenn
sie wirklich nötig sind
die universitätsklinik in wien
distanziert sich von dieser meldung
es gibt derzeit keine wissenschaftlichen
beweise für einen zusammenhang zwischen
ibuprofen und besonders schweren
krankheitsverläufen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt jetzt
dennoch vor der einnahme vorsorglich in
einer anderen nachricht die in den
sozialen medien kursiert soll angeblich
schon ein ganz einfaches mittel helfen
das virus zu bekämpfen wasser ein
schluck alle 15 minuten soll das virus
in den magen befördern und damit
unschädlich machen
wasser trinken ist nie verkehrt jetzt
das immunsystem überhaupt das jetzt das
corona aufhält
plätze wenn man ein virus hat oder eine
infektion hat oder so etwas auch bei der
grippe auch bei der normalen erkältung
da ist ja auch nichts anders also das
kann ja nicht falsch sein
das habe ich auch gehört dass das
schützen soll also dass wenn man die
während in sich trägt dass es dann raus
gespielt wird aber ich bin mir sicher
auch daran glauben soll oder nicht
in manchen versionen des kettenbrief es
wird zwar die stanford university als
quelle genannt
doch diese hat diesen hinweis nie
veröffentlicht
[Musik]
zwar ist es bei einer infektion generell
ratsam viel zu trinken denn tatsächlich
werden dadurch keime und viren im rachen
zum teil ausgespült doch der mund ist
nicht das einzige einfallstor für die
viren sie können ebenso über nase oder
augen in den körper gelangen
regelmäßiges wassertrinken ist zwar muss
und gegen eine infektion mit dem neuen
virus hilft es jedoch nicht
soziale medien sind also keine
verlässliche quelle
aber was ist mit einer empfehlung die
auf seriös wirkenden webseiten zum
beispiel von ärzten zu finden ist
vitamin d das sonnen vitamin soll einer
infektion mit dem corona virus vorbeugen
in dem zusammenhang wird unter anderem
die whu die weltgesundheitsorganisation
zitiert kann uns vitamin d tatsächlich
schützen
[Musik]
habe ich noch nicht gehört halte ich
aber auch für ziemlichen quatsch
vitamin d nimmt man wenn man kleine
kinder hat oder sonnenmangel vitamine
frische luft weil das was sonst auch das
simon system stärkt und die gesundheit
stärkt sind glaube ich auch jetzt an
geraten haben ich denke das ist für das
bringt dann alles was stimmt vitamin d
trägt zur normalen funktion des
immunsystems bei der menschliche körper
bildet das vitamin bei
sonneneinstrahlung bei einem akuten
mangel kann man zwar mit vitamin d
präparaten gegen steuern
doch es gibt keine empfehlung der whu
zur prophylaktischen einnahme gegen das
aktuelle corona virus und konkrete
studien die eine wirksamkeit von
vitaminen zur vorbeugung der korona
infektion belegen gibt es ebenfalls
nicht
ein spaziergang in der sonne kann
dennoch nicht schaden oder oberflächen
sind doch reinste ihren schleudern
viren können darauf doch stundenlang
angeblich sogar bis zu drei tage
überleben
ich denke das ist wahr ich versuche
schon grundsätzlich nichts anzufassen
weil ich das immer als abstoßend
empfunden habe sich abzusichern ist
sicherlich eher noch an stärke angesagt
als wir es im moment praktizieren wir
haben es bewusst auf den verzehr von dem
dinner im bestand verzichtet dann gehen
jetzt arbeitsstätte zurück werden
in einem labortest wurde tatsächlich
gezeigt dass neue corona virus bleibt
auf kunststoff und edelstahl bis zu 72
stunden lang infektiös die zahl der
viren nahm zwar drastisch ab aber es
reichte noch um eine zellkultur zu
infizieren
auf diese geringeren anzahl jedoch auch
genügt um einen menschen zu infizieren
lässt sich anhand dieser studie jedoch
nicht sagen
[Musik]
fakt von fake zu unterscheiden bleibt in
der flut von nachrichten schwierig wie
geht man am besten damit um
statt auf dubiose chat nachrichten oder
hörensagen zu vertrauen sollte man sich
bei seriösen medien und einrichtungen
informieren wie auf den seiten des
robert koch instituts oder der
bundesministerien
nur hier kann man sich sicher sein
die meldungen wurden geprüft so schauts
aus der bewusste umgang mit allen infos
und ganz besonders mit denen aus den
digitalen netzwerken ist im moment die
beste möglichkeit sich zu schützen
vieles was viral geht ist ungeprüft den
punkt wollen wir vertiefen mit harald
lesch professor lesch welche
falschmeldungen im zusammenhang mit
krone hat sie am meisten geärgert
die falschmeldung dass es das virus gar
nicht gibt beziehungsweise dass das
virus schon immer da gewesen ist und man
wisse doch wie man damit umgehe das
ganze sei history das ist eigentlich die
allerschlimmste falschmeldung zumal sie
auch noch von personen verteilt wird
die aus dem medizinischen bereich kommen
da bin ich wirklich also da habe ich
gemerkt wie mir die die schilddrüse die
fast so die drüse sehr hals dick wird
das ist unmöglich gewesen
erbärmlich so ist ja generell in den
wissenschaften ist das ein großes thema
kommt es immer wieder vor dauern naja
dadurch dass eben das internet als so
eine art von oder das netz insgesamt
also eine art von stammtische agiert das
was früher vielleicht in der kneipe oder
unter freunden mal so gesagt worden ist
das geht ja jetzt gleich viral der chef
von der weltgesundheitsorganisation hat
ja sogar von der info demi gesprochen
weil nämlich die informationen die
scheinbaren informationen mit
unglaublicher geschwindigkeit über den
planeten geben sich schneller ausbreiten
als das corona wir uns selber weil es
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit sich ausbreitet
über unsere netzwerke die sozialen und
weniger soziale netzwerke das heißt wir
haben es mit einer sehr starken resonanz
fläche zu tun wo sehr sehr sehr viele
völlig ungeprüften informationen
rumlaufen und auf der anderen seite ist
es auch so dass tatsächlich nachrichten
aus der wissenschaft von der
öffentlichkeit häufig völlig falsch
wahrgenommen werden
es gibt kaum erfahrung mit tatsächlichen
wissenschaftlichen fachpublikationen zum
beispiel in denen oft das wort hypothese
verwendet wird und oft wird dann bei der
transformation von dem
wissenschaftlichen inhalt in
öffentlichkeitswirksame texte wird auf
einmal aus der hypothese eine tatsache
und dann wird aus dann fängt die krise
eigentlich schon an dass man das ja so
gar nicht gesagt hat dann muss man
zurückrudern von bei allen seiten und
das verunsichert natürlich
öffentlichkeit in ganz erheblichem maße
wie anfällig sind wir oder viele
menschen dass sie eher auch fake news
klicken besonders im netz als er
wirklich seriöse quellen zu lesen
also man hat herausgefunden dass bis in
den letzten tagen jetzt ungefähr 142 mal
mehr nachrichten von fake news
weitergeleitet oder kommentiert worden
sind als die nachrichten und meldungen
von der weltgesundheitsorganisation
das heißt wir sind offenbar
außerordentlich daran interessiert noch
was anderes zu hören als das was die
offiziellen seiten geben vor allen
dingen dann wenn die offiziellen
informationsquellen nicht das sagen was
wir gerne hören möchten
und darunter liegen mit dem sogenannten
bestätigungs fehler am liebsten wäre uns
natürlich diese ganze krise wäre ein
fake es gäbe es gar nicht wir können
einfach so weitermachen wie bisher
business as usual das ist eigentlich das
was wir am liebsten haben das muss
morgen so sein wie es gestern war das
ist am angenehmsten und dann sind wir
sehr sehr anfällig für dinge die wir
sowieso schon irgendwie im tiefsten
inneren gewünscht oder geglaubt haben
und deswegen sind viele dieser fake news
so besonders attraktiv für viele
faktoren wie soll man sich am besten
informieren sie müssen jetzt keine
werbung für uns machen dabei haben sie
einen rat
na ja also ich glaube was ganz wichtig
ist und was relativ einfaches vor ort
also zum beispiel in der gemeinde in der
stadtverwaltung sich zu erkundigen wie
ist der stand der dinge wenn man
jemanden kennen die einem krankenhaus in
der hingegen arbeiten einfach mal
anrufen wissen bei euch die lage damit
man mal erfährt was wirklich los ist und
wie dramatisch die lage tatsächlich ist
und auf diese weise glaube ich hat man
besseres vertrauen hat man ein größeres
vertrauen in die nachrichten gerade auch
aus den offiziellen institutionen gibt
ja sehr sehr viele leute die aus mir
unerfindlichen gründen da extrem
misstrauisch sind und die lieber
irgendwelchen dubiosen quellen aus dem
netz glauben warum weiß ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht
diese art von misstrauen muss man sich
eigentlich auch leisten können denn wir
sehen ja eigentlich dass diese
öffentlichen institutionen im
zusammenhang mit verwaltung und politik
eine ziemlich gut funktionieren und es
wundert mich eigentlich sehr weshalb
dann nach wie vor so ein großer hang
dazu ist irgendwelche exotischen
meldungen nachzulaufen also die
öffentlichen die öffentlichen
institutionen und wir haben schon gehört
das robert-koch-institut natürlich die
homepage zu fahren und da glaube ich und
auch hier natürlich die fakten checker
von den öffentlich rechtlichen medien
das sind eigentlich die quellen wo man
sich am schnellsten erkundigen kann was
wirklich los ist sagt professor harald
specht vielen dank für diese
informationen und einschätzungen was
hilft aus ärztlicher sicht die frage ist
wichtig und auch da gibt es natürlich
fakten und fake bei uns das noch mal
dr christoph specht ist sie würde ich
gerne fragen weil wir diese frage auch
immer wieder gestellt bekommen haben
hilft eigentlich seife beim händewaschen
ganz praktische frage oder soll ich auf
jeden fall desinfektionsmittel nehmen
klare antwort seife hilft und dies auch
ausreichend die erklärung ist ganz
einfach das virus hat eine hülle drumrum
hülle klingt zunächst das wäre sehr
stabil ist es gar nicht die hülle ist
eine fett hülle das ist wie so ein fett
in der pfanne und wenn ich das mit seife
tensiden spülmittel wenn ich das an löse
dann geht die hülle kaputt und das virus
eben auch kaputt also wasser und seife
reicht völlig desinfektionsmittel kann
man natürlich auch nehmen das mache ich
aber dann bin ich unterwegs bin und
wasser und seife ich habe wieder eine
frage von den zuschauern als kleiner
film wenn du hunger hast eigentlich die
regierung zurück wann haben die den mut
irgendwie alles zurück zu nehmen und zu
sagen jetzt ist alles wieder safe ja das
ist natürlich eine million dollar frage
die wissen ja nicht wie lange diese
pandemie und diese situation anhält es
ist vollkommenes neuland auch er
eigentlich eine politische frage auch
die politiker schwimmen natürlich ein
wenig müssen sich an die virologen
halten
wir wissen es einfach nicht mag ich gehe
davon aus meine persönliche einschätzung
es dauert auf jeden fall wochen mann
wird jetzt sehr schwache und starke
maßnahmen machen und dann wahrscheinlich
sukzessive die langsam wieder zurück
fahren
denn sonst werden die leute
auch irgendwann mal ran de sich wenn das
wirklich über sehr langen zeitraum geht
darunter christoph spricht vielen dank
für diese weiteren informationen und
machen jetzt einen fliegenden wechsel
nur kurz zur erklärung wir stehen hier
nicht alle zusammen einen tisch das
machen wir natürlich aus gutem grunde
erhalten auch wirklich immer zwei meter
abstand
und darum ist jetzt wieder bei uns felix
zimmermann hier freut mich sehr aus der
rechts redaktion es gibt nämlich weitere
fragen aus dem netz eine frage ganz
konkret wenn ein land wie bayern den
katastrophenfall erklärt was bedeutet
das ganz praktisch dass es dann anders
als vorher
das ist ja geschehen genau da waren die
bayern auch wieder die ersten das gibt
erstmal den der regierung zusagen
durchgriffsbefugnisse man kann leichter
durchregieren und dann ist aber damit
auch verbunden dass man einzelnen auch
privaten aufgeben kann zu helfen
also es kann zb von privaten personen
beatmungsgeräte beschlagnahmt werden und
die bundespolizei kann auch eingesetzt
werden also das ist so ein bisschen ein
erster schritt richtung ausgangssperren
und zudem kommen jetzt gleich eine
ausgangssperre in italien und in
österreich zum teil in frankreich auch
gibt es hier noch nicht was würde das
dann ganz konkret bedeuten für uns genau
die gibt es hier noch nicht aber auch
bei uns könnte sie rechtlich kommen dass
sie das infektionsschutzgesetz vor und
wenn es so weiter geht und viele leute
weiter draußen sich versammeln und
könnte das auch der fall sein
und was die dann vorsieht das kommt
darauf an wie die genau ausgestaltet ist
und man hat eine konkrete maßnahmen da
wird gesagt dann und dann darf das haus
nur verlassen werden zum einkaufen oder
hierzu oder dazu das kommt also darauf
an wie die ausgestaltet wird von den
behörden und wie ihr zuwider handelt
demgegenüber kann unser unmittelbarer
zwang angedroht werden und es drohen
auch geldbußen bis hin zur
freiheitsstrafe möglich ausgangssperre
quarantäne das betrifft schon jetzt ein
paar eine zuschauerin hat gefragt was
mache ich dann eigentlich mit meinem und
wenn ich nicht mehr die wohnung nicht
mehr das haus verlassen da ist auch die
maßgebliche frage meiner frau da gibt es
zwei antworten wenn kantine angeordnet
ist
das ist ganz zwingend da muss man zu
hause bleiben darf man nicht mit dem
hund gassi gehen und da muss man
wirklich organisieren dass nachbarn den
hund abholen wenn es eine ausgangssperre
ist da hilft dir zb der blick nach
österreich dort ist weiter erlaubt mit
dem rundkurs gassi zu gehen
aber eben in unmittelbarer umgebung es
kommt dann wirklich darauf an was die
behörden da konkret anordnet werden
felix zimmermann vielen dank für diese
informationen die können am ende für uns
alle ganz wichtig seien vielen dank über
die jahrhunderte hat es immer wieder
pandemien gegeben eine der tödlichsten
war die pest im mittelalter oder im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert die spanische
grippe
was wusste man schon damals über diese
krankheiten welche maßnahmen hat man
ergriffen und können wird daraus etwas
für die jetzige situation eigentlich
lernen
1347 von der südküste der krim am
schwarzen meer nimmt die pest ihren
ausgang
katarische belagerer der italienischen
handels bastion kv schleudern per
katapult ihre toten in die innenstadt
und mit ihnen den schwarzen tod
der damals noch unbekannte erreger das
bakterium yersinia pestis wird zunächst
von flöhen auf ratten und später auf den
menschen übertragen
kaufleute und soldaten aus gaza führen
die ratten und mit ihnen die pest dann
nach süd europa ein von den
mittelmeerhäfen ausgehend ist in nur
vier jahren fast der gesamte der
europäische kontinent infiziert
[Musik]
wie kann man die bevölkerung schützen
wenn die tatsächliche ursache völlig
unbekannt ist in kürzester zeit läuft
die pest bewohner ganzer straßenzüge und
stellte in denn nach sintflutartigem
regen und messdaten trifft der erreger
auf einem mangelernährte und
immunschwache bevölkerung
viele wenden sich der kirche zu sein die
menschen des mittelalters sehen vor
allem höhere mächte am werk sintflut und
solche gelten als strafe gottes
die ärzte greifen zur behandlung auf
antikes aber unwirksames wissen zurück
zum beispiel aderlass allmählich erkennt
man dass isolation wird kommt zeigt
schiffe auf denen man die krankheit
vermutet werden 40 tage isoliert
aber die ratten und damit der erreger
gelangen trotzdem an land einige städte
und länder greifen rigoroser durch
grenzen werden geschlossen
kranke unter todesdrohungen isoliert in
mailand zum beispiel werden haustüren
und fenster zugemauert bewohner der
häuser werden geopfert um die
ausbreitung zu reduzieren
portale mit roma doch diese städte und
länder darunter polen kommend dadurch
glimpflich davon
die isolierung der könnten so grausam
sie auch zu jener zeit betrieben wird
zeigt seine wirkung dennoch tötet die
solche am ende 25 millionen menschen
mindestens genauso viele tote hatte im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert die sogenannte
spanische grippe die in den usa ihren
ursprung hat
der erste weltkrieg geht in sein viertes
jahr in den usa mobilisiert die
regierung hunderttausende soldaten
patient zero soll 1918 ein
amerikanischer anni koch auf der
militärbasis vor rallye in kansas
gewesen sein
an einer von geflügel übertragenen neuen
grippe variante erkrankt steckt er
mehrere soldaten an mit den us soldaten
kommt das grippevirus auf die
schlachtfelder europas dort breitet sich
die spanische grippe rasch aus ihren
namen verdankt sie der spanischen presse
die als erste über die neue krankheit
berichtet ein heilmittel gibt es nicht
die ärzte konzentrieren sich auf die
linderung der symptome
doch schon früh versuchen militär ärzte
die kranken zu isolieren und
hygienemaßnahmen wie händewaschen und
mundschutz durchzusetzen
doch an der front sind die maßnahmen
kaum durchführbar
auch nach kriegsende breitet sich das
virus weiter aus weltweit besonders
betroffen indien zurückkehrende soldaten
bringen das virus mit in ein land in dem
hungersnot und mangelnde hygiene
herrschen
es wird geschätzt dass etwa fünf prozent
der bevölkerung indiens 18 millionen
menschen an der spanischen grippe
starben
einige länder darunter die usa haben
trotz der rasanten verbreitung
vergleichsweise niedrige opferzahlen
das liegt daran dass es gelingt im
zivilen bereich verschiedene maßnahmen
durchzusetzen
besonders wichtig wie gene
in vielen städten ist der mundschutz
pflicht new yorker lässt ein spuk verbot
und vor allem menschenmengen sollen
gemieden werden
wie erfolgreich diese maßnahmen sind
zeigt sich im vergleich der städte saint
louis und philadelphia während
philadelphia zu spät maßnahmen wie
schulschließungen und
versammlungsverbote ergreift und
tausende sterben wertlos viel schneller
dadurch verlangsamt sich die verbreitung
am ende sterben dort nur 700 menschen
[Musik]
professor lesch aus der geschichte
lernen ist er in so vielen bereichen so
wichtig auch in der wissenschaft was
kann denn die forschung aus den
bisherigen epidemien oder pandemien
lernen
ich glaube die forschung hat schon sehr
viel gelernt die gesellschaft müsste vor
allen dingen lernen dass man das nicht
verhindern kann es ist immer und immer
wieder passiert dass die natur sich
verändert dass es deswegen veränderungen
gibt die uns auch krank machen können
dass die viren sich ständig verändern
und das auf diese art und weise immer
eine herausforderung da ist auf die
gesellschaft adäquat reagieren muss das
glaube ich ist ganz wichtig ansonsten
verliert man und wir erleben es ja auch
momentan ein bisschen in der reaktion
vieler leute das gefühl dafür dass wir
ein teil der natur sind und wenn die
natur sich verändert hat das natürlich
für uns konsequenzen ich glaube die
wissenschaft ist das schon sehr sehr
viel weiter als die gesellschaft war die
meisten menschen immer gedacht haben so
was kann uns ja gar nicht passieren in
den laboratorien dieser welt war das
schon immer klar das ist eigentlich nur
eine frage der zeit dass man solche
epidemien immer wieder auftauchen und so
kann uns die geschichte eigentlich sagen
jawohl diese epidemien kommen immer
wieder und wir sollten das nicht
vergessen
diese spanische grippe das war ja
wirklich eine ganz extreme erfahrung für
für die welt ganz konkret was kann man
von der lernen wir haben dem filmischen
angedeutet gesehen
also es gibt diesen etwas sperrigen
begriff der nicht pharmazeutischen
intervention np
das heißt mit anderen worten
verhaltensregeln zu verändern also
tatsächlich starke einschränkungen über
städte über in schulen so das was wir
momentan erleben das sind typische mps
also nicht pharmazeutische
interventionen die dafür sorgen sollen
dass das virus sich eben nicht schneller
ausbreitet und das ist ja etwas wenn man
sich das jetzt mal überlegt man geht zum
arzt und möchte eigentlich von dem arzt
oder der ärztin medikament bekommen
möchte ein rezept bekommen man nimmt das
und die sache ist erledigt wenn einem
der arzt dann sagt naja sie legen sich
einfach für zehn tage hin und dann wird
es wieder werden das ist eine nachricht
die man nicht so gerne hört und auch
unsere gesellschaft wird solche
nachrichten gar nicht so gerne weil sie
die macher gesellschaft ist und wie
erfahren aber jetzt aus den
untersuchungen über die spanische grippe
dass diese diese nicht pharmazeutischen
intervention das aller aller wichtigste
sind also so schnell wie
nicht so viel wie möglich und so
intensiv wie möglich das sind die städte
gewesen in den vereinigten staaten die
die spanische grippe am besten
überstanden haben und wo die sterberaten
am geringsten waren also daran können
wir uns orientieren genauso wie an den
erfahrungswerten die wir in asien in den
letzten jahren gemacht haben eine
interessante frage wer was passiert denn
dann bei der spanischen grippe nachdem
diese maßnahmen also versammlungsverbot
und schulschließungen wieder aufgehoben
wurden na ja was glauben sie das hat
natürlich wieder angefangen also in dem
moment wo man einem solchen natürlichen
phänomenen wie der raum gibt sich
auszubreiten und dann ging natürlich die
ansteckungsrate wieder hoch nicht mit
der gleichen amplitude wie ganz am
anfang weil es inzwischen auch schon
eine gewisse herdenimmunität gab aber es
gab wieder einen weiteren kick und erst
dann ist es abgeflaut das heißt wir
können auch hier sehen dass es auf jeden
fall sinnvoll sein wird diese nicht
pharmazeutischen interventionen ruhig
noch ein tag oder ein paar tage länger
zu halten dann sind wir auf der sicheren
seite
wie bewerten sie jetzt die maßnahmen die
jetzt bei uns so nach und nach
unternommen werden die vorschriften ist
es genau richtig jetzt also ich hab
gestern abend den französischen
präsidenten gehört und ich finde ich
glaube man wird tatsächlich zu solchen
noch stärker einschränkenden maßnahmen
übergehen müssen
man hat in den letzten tagen also hier
in münchen genauso wie in anderen teil
in deutschland doch gesehen dass teile
der bevölkerung noch nicht richtig
verstanden haben wie ernst die situation
ist
und wenn das nicht deutlich besser wird
wird man noch weiter einschränken müssen
dem virus ist es nämlich egal wer es
verbreitet es tut es ganz automatisch
also die immunreaktionen der jeweiligen
es sind ja gerade die methode wie das
virus sich verbreiten kann
und wenn wir das nicht stoppen dann
wären wir in absehbarer zeit deutlich
höhere infizierten zahlen haben und
damit natürlich auch deutlich höhere
zahlen an schwer erkranken und wie wir
das stemmen sollen das wird ganz ganz
schwierig also ich denke es wird die
maßnahmen sind gut aber sie werden
möglicherweise nicht ausreichen
was haben sie in ihrem leben bis jetzt
verändert in dieser situation
na ja ich bin's ich bleibe zu hause also
wichtig gerade hier fürs zdf da bin dann
bleibe ich zu hause
professor lesch ich danke ihnen sehr das
war sehr spannend vielen dank für
die informationen und einschätzungen
danke dass ihr uns geholfen haben
bleiben sie gesund sie auch liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
arbeiten auf hochtouren an einem
impfstoff die politik trifft
entscheidungen die zwar unseren alltag
massiv einschränken wie aber zwingend
notwendig sind ärztinnen und ärzte
pflegerinnen und pfleger und all
diejenigen die im medizinischen
einrichtungen arbeiten werden besonders
in den nächsten tagen außergewöhnliches
leisten müssen viele ältere menschen
machen sich große sorgen um ihre
gesundheit viele eltern müssen sich um
organisieren und alles über den haufen
werfen
viele angestellte erleiden finanzielle
einbußen manche werden sogar ihren job
verlieren unternehmen werden kämpfen
müssen manche werden den kampf verlieren
ich glaube dass diese situation vor
allem jetzt eines erfordert unsere
solidarität unser verständnis und die
mithilfe aller ich danke ihnen für ihr
interesse
das war unsere sondersendung für heute
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem heute
journal
machen sie es gut und auch wenn sie
diesen satz jetzt täglich immer wieder
hören er kommt wirklich von herzen
bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]
maybrit illner spezial mit dem thema
corona krise kampf gegen die pandemie
unter anderem mit kanzleramtsminister
helge braun jörg radek gewerkschaft der
polizei und frank ulrich montgomery chef
des welt ärzte bundes maybrit illner
spezial gleich nach dem heute journal